[Music]
for the first time in this pandemic we
are a nation restriction free
as scotland's last remaining rule of
mandatory masks is ditched the final
steps out
are in
sight at the piper's rest on edinburgh's
royal mile it's a big change for not
just its customers but staff too it
means we can concentrate on what we
enjoy doing what we do best and that's
promoting the business getting the place
busy making the customers have a good
time rather than being the covered
police and and people falling out with
you because you're telling to wear a
mask when they're walking to the toilet
and so it's definitely taking that
pressure off
but health bosses in scotland have
insisted whilst the time is right people
should continue to wear them voluntarily
it states that the law requires you to
wear a face covering unless you're
exempt but we've changed that to the
scottish government has is now
recommending that you wear a face
covering indoors something shop owner
abby is keeping firmly in place it's
when you look at what's happening and
we're not out of the woods just yet
so um it would just take one more
variant to turn up that wasn't
um
you know that it was harsher than the
rest and we would be about to square one
it's just the law that's changed it's
not the recommendations
so i still want to keep everybody as
safe as possible
for scotland and in turn the uk finally
losing all restrictions is a big change
which many hope will stay in place let's
remember thanks to the vaccines
treatments and our better understanding
of the virus the situation is
transformed but the thing we are always
looking out for is a new variant and if
we get one that is more severe of course
we may have to ask people to really take
up those protective behaviors again but
science needs to do its work in the
meantime
for scotland's first minister a close
shave nicola sturgeon briefly seen
unmasked in a barber shop at the weekend
hours before the rules were eased police
scotland today reminded her to follow
the law but will not be investigating
any further
there's no doubt masks have changed our
way of life the power of a small cloth
etched into our legal history and even
though they're now not required they're
very much here to stay intimate rashid
sky news edinburgh